hi everyone
this is professor m science and today
we're going to talk about the wave
function of coherent states
in another one of our videos on rigorous
quantum mechanics if you've been
following our series on coherence dates
then you know number one that coherent
states are defined as the eigen states
of the lowering operator
and number two that coherent states are
called quasi-classical states because
they are the quantum states that most
closely resemble the motion of a
classical harmonic oscillator
what we want to do today is to discuss
the properties of the wave function
of coherence states we will learn that
the coherent state wave function is
essentially a displacement of the ground
state wave function so you won't be
surprised to hear that it has a gaussian
shape you will also learn
how coherent states are minimum
uncertainty states
and we will also see how the wave
function of coherence states
actually undergoes the back and forth
motion that we typically associate
to classical harmonic oscillators we'll
get started by directly writing down
the coherent state wave function without
explicitly going through its
mathematical derivation but
we do have a video where we go step by
step through
that mathematical derivation it's linked
in the description so don't forget to
check it out
so let's go let's start with a quick
refresher of the quantum harmonic
oscillator
the hamiltonian h is equal to the
kinetic energy
plus the quadratic potential energy we
can also write this down
in terms of the raising and lowering
operators
or in terms of the number of eraser
this is the eigenvalue equation of the
hamiltonian
where en are the eigenvalues and the ket
n are the eigen states the eigenvalues e
n are quantized
and are equal to h bar omega times
n plus one half where n is a
non-negative
integer we can navigate the associated
eigenstates
using the ladder operators so if we
consider
the real axis and place an energy
eigenvalue here
with the associated energy eigenstate
acting on eigenstate n with the lowering
operator
gives a new eigenstate n minus one where
the energy has decreased by a quantum of
energy
similarly acting on eigenstate n with
the raising operator
gives a new eigenstate n plus one
where the energy has increased by a
quantum of energy
so this is it for the quick refresher
and you can find
many more details in our series on the
quantum harmonic oscillator that is
linked in the description
let's next take a look at coherent
states of
the quantum harmonic oscillator a
coherent state
alpha is defined as the eigen state of
the lowering operator with eigenvalue or
alpha
as usual these here are the eigenvalues
and these here are the eigen states as
the lowering operator is not hermitian
the eigenvalues are in general complex
numbers
we can actually write coherent states in
a variety of alternative
but equivalent forms so let's start
writing it in the energy basis
a coherent state alpha is equal to this
pre-factor
times an infinite sum over the weighted
energy eigenstates
an alternative form involves the use of
the displacement operator
the displacement operator d alpha is
defined as the exponential function of
this sum over
ladder operators we can then write the
coherent state alpha as equal to the
action of the displacement operator
on the ground state of the quantum
harmonic oscillator
again you can find many more details
about all of these concepts by
following the relevant links in the
description so what we will do today
is to consider the expression of the
coherent state alpha
in the position representation or to put
it another way
we'll study the wave function of
coherent
states
let's go straight to the coherent state
wave function
for a coherent state alpha we write the
wave function
as psi alpha of x and it is equal to the
bracket between the position eigenstate
x and the coherent state alpha
in the companion video to this one we go
through the mathematical calculation of
this wave function
and the answer that we find there is
that the wave function of a coherent
state alpha
is given by the product of this
exponential multiplying
this other exponential multiplying the
displaced
ground state wave function of the
quantum harmonic oscillator
let's start with the phase theta alpha
here
if we copy it down it is equal to minus
the real part of alpha
times the imaginary part of alpha
this term here is the expectation value
of the momentum operator in state alpha
and is equal to this prefactor times
alpha minus alpha star
this term here is the expectation value
of the position operator
in state alpha and is equal to this
other prefactor
times alpha plus alpha star and from the
video on quantum harmonic oscillator
eigenfunctions
we also know that this wave function
here
is the ground state wave function of the
quantum harmonic oscillator
which is equal to this pre-factor times
this gaussian exponential again for the
mathematical derivation of this result
make sure you check out the companion
video and what we will do today
is to explore the properties of this
wave function
which will teach us a number of really
important features
of coherent states
first let's calculate the absolute value
squared of the wave function which gives
the probability distribution
of the particle position it is simply
equal to the absolute value squared of
the displaced gram state
and this is true because this term and
this term have magnitude 1.
if we recall again the form of the
ground state wave function
which is equal to this pre-factor times
this exponential then we can spell out
the absolute value squared of the
coherent stateway function
as equal to this pre-factor times this
exponential
we now need to remember a result from
the video on quasi classical states
linked in the description the root mean
square deviation of the position
operator in a coherent state
is equal to this constant factor
rearranging we get that m omega over h
bar
is equal to one over two times the root
mean square deviation of
x all squared
inserting this expression into this term
in the exponential
and into this term in the pre-factor
we conclude that we can rewrite the
absolute value squared of the coherence
stage wave function
as equal to this pre-factor times
this exponential
and now we can clearly see the form of
the coherent stateway function
it is a gaussian it is a gaussian
centered at the expectation value of the
position operator here
and whose width is equal to the root
mean square deviation
of the position operator here
this result makes sense the hearing
state wave function is essentially the
displaced ground state of the quantum
harmonic oscillator
and the ground state is itself a
gaussian
so what can we learn from the fact that
we got a gaussian for the wave function
of a coherent state
in the video on quasi classical states
we find that the root mean square
deviation of the position operator in a
coherent state
is equal to this constant factor
and we also learn that the root mean
square deviation of the momentum
operator
is equal to this other constant factor
multiplying delta x with delta p we get
this constant factor times this other
constant factor the masses cancel here
and here
and the frequencies also cancel here and
here
and overall we get h bar over 2.
now remembering that the heisenberg
uncertainty principle says that
for any state delta x multiplied by
delta p
is larger than or equal to h bar over
two
then we see that for coherent states we
have a situation where this
here becomes an equal sign
and this means that coherent states are
minimum
uncertainty states and we know from the
video on minimum uncertainty states
that they always take a gaussian form
so all in all this result is consistent
with our earlier discussion about the
gaussian form of coherent state wave
functions
coherent states are minimum uncertainty
states so the wave functions
had to be of gaussian form
for the next property i want to discuss
we need to remember that a coherent
state alpha
can be written as the action of the
displacement operator d alpha
on the ground state so let's draw the
real axis
where we will plot the coordinate x and
we also place the origin
let's first consider the ground state of
the quantum harmonic oscillator here
we can draw the absolute value squared
of the ground state wave function
as a gaussian centered at the origin
next let's consider the current state
alpha here
in this case we can draw the absolute
value squared of the coherent state as
another gaussian
but now its center has been displaced to
this new position
this provides a new perspective on our
understanding of coherent states
and displacement operators a coherent
state is simply a displacement of the
gaussian ground state wave function
from the origin to this position here
and this displacement is provided by the
action of the displacement operator
acting on the ground state or to put it
another way
the displacement operator displaces the
ground state wave function
to generate a coherent state
let's next consider the time evolution
of the coherent gateway function
from the video on coherent states we
know that if the initial state of our
system
is a coherent state alpha zero then the
state of the system at a later time t
is equal to a global phase factor times
another coherent state alpha
where alpha is equal to alpha zero times
this phase
or to put it another way a coherent
state stays
coherent at all times
now what does this look like in terms of
wave functions
we could write out the full wave
function up here as an arbitrary time
point
by simply using the corresponding
coherent state eigenvalue alpha
at each time however what we will do
instead
is to directly consider the time
dependence of the absolute value squared
of the wave function because that will
be a more enlightening calculation
for our purposes it is also pretty
straightforward to evaluate as it is
simply the absolute value squared of the
displaced ground state wave function
but now the displacement is time
dependent because the coherent state
evolves according to this expression up
here
we can also use this explicit expression
for the absolute value squared
to rewrite it as this prefactor times
this gaussian exponential
in this latest expression the coherent
state features in two places
the first is the expectation value of
the position operator here
and we actually calculated the time
dependence of this expectation value in
the video on
quasi classical states and the answer is
that we get this pre-factor
times this cosine term where the face
phi
depends on the initial conditions
the second place where the coherent
state features is in the root mean
square deviation of the position
here and here and we also found on the
video on quasi classical states
that the root mean square deviation in
state alpha
is actually a time independent constant
so what does this mean the coherence
date wave function
is a gaussian whose center oscillates
back and forth
according to this equation and the
oscillation occurs at frequency omega
on top of that the gaussian does not
spread over time
because its width given the root mean
square deviation of the position here
is constant
so what does the evolution in time
actually look like
the expression is not very intuitive so
let's add some action
and look at an animation this wave
packet in red
is like a hearing state whose initial
position is at one extreme of the
oscillatory motion here
if we then start our time revolution we
can clearly see the back and forth
motion that we expect for a harmonic
oscillator
with the center of the wave packet
following this equation here
this motion makes it very clear that
coherence states move like classical
particles
in a harmonic os laser and we can also
see
as we just discussed that the wave
packet does not spread in time
because the root mean square deviation
here is constant
and these are all characteristic
features of coherent states
i always like seeing the coherent state
wave function going back and forth
it allows us to see really clearly the
connection between
our everyday macroscopic world and the
microscopic quantum world also
don't forget to check out the
mathematical derivation of the form of
the coherence state wave function
in the companion video and as always if
you liked this video
please subscribe